people have been telling me about this
thing called cameo where you can get you
can pay money to a celebrity and a
celebrity will make a message for you
right and it's nice to you I've seen a
couple of them and I understand that
this is something you're doing now yeah
I'm doing cameo it's come to this you
know I had an HBO special a couple years
ago now I'm like selling people birthday
messages on an app it's fine they have
been emailing me about it for a while
and I was just avoiding and now I'm like
I lost you know all my touring gigs for
the year so yeah I'll tell you you know
Congrats on your anniversary for $35 a
pop like I guess I'm okay with that now
it's actually turned out pretty fun is
that your rate is it $35 it is it used
to be 25 but then I was poking around
and there's a this is very egotistical
but I found another comedian who I think
is good like but they I was at 25 and
they were at 35 and I was like they're
not they're not $10 better no way I just
matched Larry I was it because it's such
a weird thing when you cuz I didn't
realize I said first but they make you
put an actual monetary value on your own
worth you have to sit there go what am i
worth yeah when I saw this other
comedian I was like no way no way
they're not obviously you can't tell me
who the other comedian is no and they're
great there's someone I like but there
ain't a $10 better I'm much more
experienced that's great can't do that
for my self-esteem I would think about
it all day oh that's like doesn't seem
like it feels like this is a good way
for you to earn some income right now it
is it is most of my income has come via
this one guy named Randy in Gainesville
Florida cuz he got Kovac and a friend I
guess he's a phantom on a friend of his
body cameo and then like two more came
in and I was like is this the same Randy
and then they all thought I was funny so
I got like 9 things telling Randy to
heal up and then he got out so I got
like four more to tell Randy congrats on
getting out of hospital then he got
engaged so I got like two or three more
that were like can you congratulate
Randy and Jessica it was just Jessica's
birthday so Randy bought one so I've got
that made like a lot
money off this guy Randy in Gainesville
Chris yeah Hospital yeah yeah you're not
supposed to charge them to get well all
right your show is still on the air mine
got canceled
okay my got canceled like a year and
half ago okay Chris this kid they don't
think he's gonna make it and we'd love
it if you would say hang in there I'm
praying for you and you're like okay
where's my money I'm like 25 bucks and
do it fast cuz I'm bumping it up to 35
okay
I'm bumping up to 35 any day now let's
get it rolling let's get it rolling
I saw one cameo that comes to mind I
think it was Todd bridges from facts of
life did a cameo where he wished someone
a happy birthday and I swear to God I
think he was standing in a very small
bathroom backed up against a Kurt like a
a plastic crinkled shower curtain yeah
most of mine are like this close to my
face
okay I heard it's your birthday it's
tuck staff birthday during the
quarantine yeah Cecelia tells me you
really love dogs yeah a birthday sorry I
know you're a big fan sorry to hear that
you've got weeks to live but where's my
money he's getting married though he he
invited me he tweets at me now I feel
like I know this guy like I dunno I've
learned so much and say here's the
ethical question let's see you get
invited to the wedding
that's a personal appearance I will say
this because you've made me feel bad
Randy if you see this not only will I
attend your wedding I am a registered
Reverend at the First Nations ministry
and I will be the Reverend at your
wedding - Jessica if you want $435 35
more dollars yes and let's do it in
person please so cameo doesn't get a cut
of that one-piece okay yeah you cut out
the middleman you don't need cameo